we get comfortable and if you ever see
my hand back here I'm scratching Drew's
back that's what's happening I'll pull
the muscle there's not a gat here I'm
massaging him he's helping I got you
appreciate that people are like I wonder
if Greg gets on his female guests no but
drew that's an exception where Serena
ordered me in files tomorrow hello there
reject nation I'm Greg Alba then I'm M
dogfish revelation that's his name if
you guys haven't seen the struggle
nation YouTube channel I'm telling you
it's one of the best reaction channels
out there but lately they're trying to
be more than reactions mm-hmm I don't
know why but they just put out a short
film called Dawn of the Dead by Dawn and
Evil Dead story I did a reaction to it
for their YouTube channel I'll tell you
guys this if you like horror if you like
Evil Dead it's violent well produced
well made I enjoy the hell out of it and
there's a link at the description box to
go check it out so please go check it
out as soon as you can we're not gonna
cover that right now we're gonna cover
this one of our top of work tiers on
patreon with everybody requesting was
definitely doing put up on YouTube but
today comes from a man named Michael B
Omni media youtuber himself this is
called crisis on Infinite Earths
theatrical trailer fan made from a
channel that ECOMOG over here is very
much familiar ultros Sargent was
obsessed to ever do it like this dude is
incredible like he makes these trailers
that is so good they look real he has
the bumpers in there and everything like
you'll swear it was real so much work
goes into these and I've been waiting to
see this and haven't seen it yet I'm so
excited I made him stop everything he
was doing it and put this on so I can't
wait to watch it
I've ever seen this guy's channel oh
you're gonna give her street everything
is as it should be
the stage is set all of us are now
worlds will die
the universe
we'll never be the same
[Music]
crisis is coming the monitor thinks
they're facing the collision of reality
I've traveled from Meijer to Warren oh
cool a crisis is imminent
someone is coming someone far far more
problem within myself
[Music]
this is
[Music]
and these other words
three
[Music]
oh it's sweet
[Music]
No
[Music]
the monitor you got him to change our
destiny somehow your card change your
destinies buried by being this she runs
that you always happen over a man so are
you not as good as you think I am but
because of you
think I'll get there someday
to appreciating what you have
Oh
to understand what I'm about to tell you
you need to do something first do you
need to believe in the impossible can
you do that Oh what
so many ways the others
[Music]
okay
figured you could use a hand wait you're
running to Mars actually
you
Batman's room
I realize useful
the anti-monitor wants to destroy all
the Earth's in the multiverse can't let
that happen
so I don't belong be found by knowing
your true soul this is awesome
doing
the first plan that you cover in this
document
eventually everything
[Music]
what
example five where we are and the way
you've been using your
you don't have a mouth
[Music]
oh man
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
what are you doing here
oh diam Oh God
thank you Michael B and drew who just
happens to what's this guys I don't hit
up people like hey you know this channel
or video you want to come over it's like
they show up and I go hey I got a few of
these which ones can we do who and so
this is pretty cool yeah that was
awesome yeah I am so looking forward to
the four-part crossover same way I'm
gonna in December I'm not fully caught
up on every show right I'm not either
but I will catch up arrow has the last
season just start airing the second last
season I just finished recently okay
which by the way you watch a show I
stopped watching because of a character
that I can't stand that I hate who
Felicity she makes my heart which I have
a personal hatred well you be happy with
the thing that made me sad that that
season ended and apparently it was
Felicity's last episode and that's why
I'm watching the last season and I had
no idea that was gonna it's like the way
ended was like it was an interesting
cliffhanger for Felicity and then I
decided to look up information about her
season 8 because it was like oh that's
gonna premiere soon so I want to watch
the trailer finally and then I was like
wait what Felicity's not in it anymore
I was so so out two completely different
responses to that information because
that just bum me out yes so much yes
whatever you know I got the one thing
that I wanted well you missed some
plenty of great seasons of arrow Oliver
Queen Farrell is easily Barbara's like
really down Valdiserri I mean I was
better than when Laura Queen when they
go ahead to Sudan because I don't know
what that was lorig weird supposed to be
Christ on it for this this was a it's
like there's no way the crossover could
even live up to what he pulled from
every movie in Jo and like yeah I got
everyone was so much of it yes I thought
it was just gonna be in tribute with the
shows and it was above and beyond and he
actually worked on this with two other
channels so it was like a close
collaboration but all of his trails are
on that level
which I saw it air all the stuff he
makes the custom logos and everything so
it looks like a real promo well the
splicing he would do of like the amount
of Tom Welling in the suit that he was
able to put together or superimposing
characters and scenes and like digitally
removing characters from stuff and then
superimposing a different character in
that moment one of the many times he did
it at the balloon I recall right now is
when Henry Kapil's on the farm
mhm and then Tom Welling shows up to
talk to him and instead of putting Lois
Lane there he had Tom Welling and then
he had them you know kiss each other
the to Superman's go at it that was a
great moment where you're watching these
two Superman's just making love to one
oh they watch the same trailer my mind
kind of drifted off in a different
direction first so we gotta watch it
again let's watch it again guys he
pulled from like the Michael Keaton the
DC Universe shows Titans new Patrol
Swamp Thing yeah Constance Adam West
everybody was in there everyone was in
here I was really impressed with how
flawless this looked and especially with
like if there's a lot of color
correcting he would have to do in order
to make it really flow well together
because all those shows have a different
aesthetic to it so I was really
surprised I didn't realize we were
watching a five-minute video I thought
this is gonna be like a two minute
trailer I wasn't surprised because I
know what he can do this dude is so
incredible that is sometime he streams
himself and when he does editing and I
will go to the stream he's like no you
can't watch I'm working on new videos
like that guy got
leave how does he only have 26,000 I
don't know I don't know this is like
incredible he's amazing and also yeah I
mean and then the timing of the editor -
yeah music cues I thought was great yeah
and they were clearly parts where I I've
always impressed with the engineering of
audio yeah when I'm like wait that scene
had music how'd you get the music out of
that and only get their dialogue like
there was plenty of moments like that as
well this is so much bigger than the
view the crossovers crossovers only four
shows and then a couple of other you
know the small bills in there and then
you got Adam Weston and I am West okay
I'm Conroy Kevin Conroy that part and
that that do me for a little I don't
expect that when I watch this trail is
it gets me so hype I wanted to stand up
because the music is going dialogue is
going into action so flawless I'm like I
can't believe I'm looking at this oh my
goodness he's so good oh my goodness
he's so good and because it's five
minutes long you feel like you're
getting this bollocks yeah yeah just a
tease for something in it of itself is
this pure energy of epicness that is
just strongly communicated and felt that
was awesome I'm glad you finally about
Ulta sorry because this do is one of the
greatest to ever do it very impressive
Oh sergeant get a man and I'm really
gonna miss Oliver Queen I have to you
avail deserve a stroke would have failed
why he talks is so soft to like other
people on the team then he gets Marilyn
this I don't condone this
so Scouter here I'm sorry I'm sorry
please forgive him subscribe to ultra
sergeant as soon as you can you can
subscribe to the real rejects click our
notification builder get notified
whenever we got a youtube video I'll
check out the struggle nation YouTube
channel their short films is linked in
the description box Michael B thanks so
much for requesting this man Michael B
has his own channel Omni media you love
this guy I mean it doesn't live out here
but one day I think you guys would have
such great rapport reactions as well
nice he's very insightful and an
incredibly analytical mindset superhot
girlfriend like super super hot guys and
girls are always hitting on his
girlfriend in public and he's constantly
having to
and off these people it doesn't fight
the men off because he's worried he'd
get his ass kicked but the women he hits
says get away from my girl kicks him to
the curb okay it's all in defense of
protecting the woman he loves fan of
gosh cheats on him constantly but he
can't do any better
check out Omni media they wanted you to
watch this video so it's all good it all
balances out